how do you think it might have gone
wrong this is the worst box office
opening in 28 years for Pixar I still
think Disney is up against itself here
are you gonna pay to take your family to
the cinema or are you just gonna wait a
couple of months and watch it I I think
the audience now is a little bit spoiled
in that sense because they know that
within a couple months a movie like this
will end up on Disney plus watching
movies these days is very expensive so
you know we're looking at 20 U.S per
ticket if you're taking a family before
you're looking almost like 100 bucks
including concessions and stuff so do
that or wait you know until it streams
and everybody can sit at home
unfortunately Elemental is just one of
these movies that has gone down the
tubes with everybody it's a tough one
for Pixar for sure it's in the Disney
Family along with Indiana Jones which
also has underperformed the US box
office yeah who was thinking that well
except Indiana Jones can't do well
exactly you think these things have sort
of re you know they're like oh well mine
or old IP because we know that will
definitely get bums on seats and it
hasn't worked